- [Voiceover] In this
video we're going to go
through an example reaction
that uses Le Chatelier's principle.
So what we're gonna do is,
we're gonna apply Le Chatelier's principle
to look at various
changes to this reaction
when we perturb our
reaction from equilibrium.
Just as a reminder,
what do I mean when I say,
This reaction is at equilibrium.?
So what that means is we
have a reversible reaction.
We have the forward reaction
which has some rate K forward.
The reverse reaction
has some rate K backward
and a dynamic equilibrium.
These rate are equal to each other,
so all of the concentrations
are going to stay constant,
and then what we do is we
decide to see what happens
when we add some carbon dioxide gas.
If we add carbon dioxide gas,
the concentration of carbon
dioxide gas will go up,
or you can think about it
as a partial pressure going up.
And Le Chatelier's principle tells us,
that if we had a reaction at equilibrium
and then we perturbed
it by adding more CO2,
it will shift to try to reduce
the effect of that change.
It will favor the reverse
reaction, so if we add CO2,
what happens is, we favor our reactants.
Another way we can see this
is by looking at the equilibrium
constant for this reaction.
We can write our equilibrium constant K,
where this is a capital K.
It's kind of confusing,
but I will try to make
this look like a capital K.
(laughs)
We can write it in two ways,
we can write it in terms
of the molar concentration,
and if we write Kc,
the expression will be
the product concentration,
our CO2 gas concentration.
And that's it, because
when we write out Kc,
we write out concentrations of gases
and we write out
concentrations of solutions,
but we don't include solids.
Kc is just the concentration
of CO2 at equilibrium.
I'm going to write an eq there
just to show that's the
equilibrium concentration.
I said that you can also write it
in terms of partial pressures,
so there's our fancy capital
K with a p subscript,
which means that instead
of concentrations,
we're writing everything for gases
in terms of partial pressures.
We have the partial
pressure of CO2 and again,
that's it, because
everything else is a solid,
so we don't include those in
our equilibrium expression.
Writing these expressions
out will be really helpful
for our second condition.
We're going to think about what happens,
when you increase
the volume of our container.
We can rewrite the partial pressure,
actually, in terms of the volume,
so if you use the ideal gas law,
the partial pressure of CO2 is equal to
the moles of CO2
times RT
divided by the volume.
Similarly, we can rewrite
molar concentration in terms
of moles divided by volume.
If we increase the
volume of our container,
increasing the volume, since
it's in the denominator,
will make our pressure go down,
so our partial pressure
of CO2 will go down
and we won't be at equilibrium anymore
and the same for the concentration,
since our perturbation
is decreasing the carbon
dioxide concentrations,
Le Chatelier's principle says,
that our reaction will try
to counteract that change.
It will try to get back to equilibrium
and try to get the CO2
concentration back up,
so it will have to favor products.
Our reaction will favor
the products to try to get
the moles of CO2 back up,
so that we get back to the
equilibrium concentration of CO2
and the equilibrium partial pressure.
The third change we're gonna look at
is what happens when you add argon gas.
Argon gas is an inert gas.
We don't expect it to react to anything.
One thing that will happen
when you add the argon gas is
it will increase the overall
pressure of your container,
so it will increase the total pressure.
But that actually doesn't tell us
what it does to our equilibrium.
Let's look back at our
equilibrium expressions Kc and Kp.
We can see that the partial
pressure for Kp only depends
on the moles of our CO2 and our volume.
Since we didn't change the moles of CO2
and we also didn't change the volume.
Even though we increased P-total,
the partial pressure
of CO2 stayed the same.
That means we didn't perturb
our reaction from equilibrium
and since we didn't perturb
it from equilibrium,
there'll be no shift.
We are still at equilibrium.
The concentrations will
still stay the same.
What happens when we add
more calcium carbonate?
That's our starting
material and it is a solid.
Our equilibrium expressions are determined
by our CO2 concentrations,
so adding more calcium carbonate,
which is a solid,
isn't actually going
to perturb our reaction
from equilibrium.
Our reaction is still
going to be at equilibrium
and we will get no
shift in concentrations.
We're actually gonna
look at one more thing.
We're going to think about what happens
when you add a catalyst.
Let's say we want to
speed up this reaction.
We can envision what's going on here
when we add the catalyst
by using an energy diagram.
If we have an energy diagram.
We have energy on the Y axis
and we're looking at
the difference in energy
between our reactants,
or starting materials,
with our products
and I just sort of made up
these relative energies.
The way that I have this drawn here,
we can see that our product
is lower energy than our starting material
and our forward rate,
Kf, which is is up here,
is determined by the size
of this activation barrier
between our starting material
and our transition state.
Our backward rate, Kb,
is determined by the size
of this energy barrier,
so the difference in energy
between the product and
our transition state.
If we add a catalyst to our reaction,
we can think about it as
lowering the activation energy
for our reaction
and that means we have
a lower energy barrier
for our forward reaction,
so our forward reaction
is gonna get faster,
but it's also gonna lower the
rate of our backward reaction.
K backward, or Kb, is also gonna speedup
and since it speeds up both the forward
and the backward reactions
adding a catalyst also
won't perturb your reaction
from equilibrium.
Adding a catalyst will result
in no shift in concentrations.
So the main things to remember
from this problem, I think.
the things I find most tricky anyway,
are that adding an inert gas,
it'll increase your total pressure,
but it won't actually change
any of your partial pressures.
It won't shift your
reaction from equilibrium
and the same thing is true
for solids and catalysts.
All of those three things: inert gases,
solids, and catalysts,
will not shift your
reaction from equilibrium.